The stories that,
that we tell and that we live in are fundamentally ways that we deal with the
complexity of the world.
And the fundamental problem with the world as far as I can tell,
is that not only is it complex beyond your comprehension,
but the complexity shifts in unpredictable ways.
So that's the Darwinian conundrum actually.
That's why Darwinism seems to be a practical necessity with regards to the
continuation of life,
because because of the complexity changes unpredictably,
you can't necessarily tell what's going to work in the future.
And so the Darwinian process solves that by generating quasi random
variations and letting,
whichever one by happenstance happens to work in that environment survive now.
And it's not random precisely because the underlying structure is conserved.
It's very rare that a child would be born with an extra arm or something like
that.
And like the skeletal structure that you inhabit is shared by animals going way,
way back in evolutionary history.
There's a lot of conservation and in the evolutionary process,
but so there's variation within conservation,
like music.
It's a good,
it's a good way of thinking about it.
And so
the,
the stories that we tell have exactly the same structure.
They,
they have this,
his core element with variations.